all right we're gonna have a little fun
now my friends or we're gonna cry
because it has gotten so bad and
embarrassing um you might remember what
was previously known as donald trump's
worst interview of all time colloquially
and it was when jonathan swann from
axios interviewed donald trump and trump
held up various things and said but you
can't do that about covid and it was a
crazy interview you might also remember
the other contender for trump's worst
interview of all time when he was
interviewed by chris wallace and told
chris wallace
that chris wallace wouldn't do that well
on a dementia test which was completely
off the charts we have a new interview
for you today that i submit is a top
contender for trump's most embarrassing
pathetic interview of all time this was
a much promoted interview
where the interviewer is none other than
my pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
who we sometimes know of colloquially as
mike pillow the back story is that trump
and pillow
became friends sort of at the start of
the pandemic when pillow went to the
white house and announced he'd be making
masks and he'd be making different
things instead of just pillows and this
has been a guy who has been one of the
most off the deep end uh advocates of
the big lie making claims about the
supreme court is going to reverse the
election results and trump obviously won
and i've got routers and i've got packet
captures and i've got a symposium or a
symbolium as he would call it all these
different things cartoonish up there
with sydney powell
so mike pillow scores an interview with
donald trump for some reason we don't
know
trump is wearing a tuxedo
and it's like it might just be
they agreed to do this when trump was at
a fundraiser and just walked off stage
wearing a tux and then was interviewed
we don't know it just adds to the
hilarity um and let's just jump right in
here is donald trump continuing to push
the big lie that he won in 2020 and he
says um uh oh
pay
see if you pay attention carefully you
know how trump does this thing where he
says sir where it where when he's lying
i don't even know what i'm doing sir
right when trump says sir they came to
me they said sir it's a tell that he's
making up the story there's another
example of one of these tells uh see if
you can pick it out here
we know what happened right you see it
in the reports you see it in everything
and also they're guarding they're so
guarding it they don't want to give the
votes they don't want to give the
ballots
mail-in ballots are a disaster they
basically use covet-19 or the china
virus to rig the election and it's a
shame
and i hope the republicans get talked so
that was it when trump says and it's a
shame
it's another tell that is saying
something that's not true
the china virus as he calls it was not
used to rig the election and so when he
says it's a shame it's like when he says
they came to me and they said sir he's
lying mitch mcconnell's a disaster the
guy's a disaster the old crow
he should have never approved that he
should have never allowed and it was
very sad when mike pence
gave those votes over because
mike pence didn't give any votes over
mike pence had nothing mike pence
couldn't give the election to trump it
wasn't up to pence who becomes the next
president more votes than you have
voters when you have other things that
are so wrong and that was then
now since then many other things have
happened
which showed that you were right and i
was right and people were right that
we're looking at it right it's a very uh
yep so there is a sort of um uh uh
self-congratulatory announcement from
donald trump that he was right and
pillow was right then in the next moment
donald trump tells mike pillow we don't
have freedom of the press anymore in
this country and that will soon lead to
communism we don't have freedom with the
press anymore
and you're absolutely right that's the
first step toward communism
so um listen guys if we didn't have
freedom of the press
mike pillow would not have been allowed
to do half the things he's been allowed
to do on various media networks over the
last six to 12 months that's if there's
any proof that we have freedom of the
press it's mike lindell's media presence
over the last six to 12 months trump
then talks about this is his sort of
like pity me routine where trump
mentions all the money he lost being
president of the united states
i expected to lose a lot of money right
i lost billions i expected that i was
okay right yeah
now
that appears to be a lie in a couple of
different ways
it is true
that during the course of trump's
presidency
his supposed personal net worth declined
but why is that it's because trump was
lying about his net worth for a very
very long time we discovered while trump
was president that he was less wealthy
than he claimed to be and indeed he also
dropped off the forbes richest 400 list
and all of this different stuff but
remember that donald trump made 1.6
billion during his presidency an average
of 400 million dollars per year uh and
he wants us to believe that he he did a
great public service he was willing to
lose billions in order to be president
of the united states trump of course no
trump interview now is complete what are
the what what has to be in any trump
interview he refers to someone calling
him sir he tells a lie and says that
it's a shame he claims that he won the
2020 election
uses the term china virus and of course
of course complains about being banned
from social media how are you feeling
then i mean is it was it like a
disbelief or was it not you know so i
had hundreds of millions of people too
we had a tremendous whether it was
twitter or uh it was instagram facebook
i had you know
just massive numbers of people and all
of a sudden
uh one day you wake up and you don't
have that voice anymore
he woke up and it was gone it was just
gone he didn't have it anymore um then
this is maybe the most delusional part
of the actually no mike pillow at the
end of the interview is even worse than
this and we'll get to that but this is
maybe the most delusional part of the
interview
trump starts talking about specific
states again he talks about arizona
and he's like we need
one big one and two smalls or we might
be able to do it with just two bigs he's
talking about the states he needs to win
it's almost december of 2021
this election was almost 13 months ago
he's still talking about the math
that'll get him to to a win
in last year's election you've said this
you know fixed 20 21st well i think it's
important that they know what happened
in 2020 and once you know what happened
they have a decision to make look
i think enough people know what happened
you look at arizona we don't need all
those things we need two big ones and
three small ones i guess separately you
can have two big ones or you can have
three small ones something like that but
we know what happened right yeah you see
it in the reports you see it in
everything and also they're guarding
they're so guarding it they don't want
to give the votes they don't want to
give the ballots
mail-in ballots are a disaster they
basically use trump voted by mail
remember covet 19 or the china virus
to rig the election and it's a shame
okay so now we get into what we listened
to before so he's still talking micro
like listen pillow if we get
georgia
and arizona and pennsylvania this thing
is over
uh sir joe biden's been president for
almost a year what what are you talking
about no no no no with two big states
and three small ones and we're right
back in the white house mike i'm telling
you in insane and then now let me get to
maybe
the craziest moment of the interview
interviewer mike lindell from mypillow
is almost in tears over how great of a
president trump was now remember as
idiotic and pathetic as we believe this
to be
there are tons of trump supporters that
also tear up when they
reminisce about the great presidency of
trump look at this that's the way god
intended it because everything that you
did
to show us what great leadership should
be right and what it can manifest to to
help all people whoever alive and to
have a great life in this country the
best country in the world and i want to
thank you as millions do for being the
greatest president we've ever had
and uh we appreciate you it's really an
honor and the good news is we're going
to look back at what they did and we're
going to say they did a terrible job so
they won't be able to talk right because
the job they've done is record setting
bad
and we're going to take back our contest
thank you mike god bless you thank you
very much thank you god bless
uh god bless
the united sheish um what a bizarre
bizarre interview and it's almost you
watch it and you're like nothing could
top the things trump is saying while
sitting strangely while wearing the
tuxedo
and then pillows almost in tears over
what he believes to have been the
greatest president in the history of the
united states you saturday night live is
out of business folks saturday night
live is out of business
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat we sometimes are combining
all sorts of different vitamins
supplements different things that may be
relevant to us ag-1 by athletic greens
is a delicious drink that just
simplifies the entire thing it's one
product you get all of the things you
need 75 vitamins minerals and whole food
sourced ingredients it's a multivitamin
it's a multi-mineral it's a probiotic
green food blend in one daily serving
really easy high quality
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes